khattar abou diab merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors la mission
de la finul à la frontière entre le
liban et israël est donc prolongé d'un
an
cette prolongation de son mandat ne fait
pourtant pas l'unanimité comment
expliquez-vous ce compromis
il faut bien le rappeler cette force
intérimaire des nations unies au liban
est sur place depuis 1978
c'est une très longue mission mais
surtout depuis 2006 la dernière guerre
la barre il y avait un renforcement de
la finul on l'a mis sous les chapitres 6
crise comme on disait pas les chapitres
7 à cause d'un conflit au sein des
conseils sécurité cette fois ci les
états unis d'amérique estimé que la fine
il n'assume pas ses charges n'assume pas
sa fonction et elle demandait elle
voulait vraiment faire beaucoup de
modifications dont le mandat de la finul
mais aussi une baisse de 30 de la finir
c'est qu'elle a obtenu une baisse des
troupes
elle n'a pas obtenu une modification
significative mais cet appel au
gouvernement libanais s'est plus ou
moins et un compromis qui s'est tramé
mais elle l'admission trombe comme à
propos d'autres questions ne parvient
pas à diriger maintenant les exercices
de la diplomatie multilatérale et
n'arrive pas à faire revoir valoir ses
idées au sein des conseils de sécurité
alors qu'est ce que la finul pourra
réaliser en un an alors que sa mission a
commencé il ya 22 ans déjà
écoutez la situation là-bas des liens
maintenant très sensible on a beaucoup
de négociations maintenant autour de ce
qu'on appelle des tracé de frontières
soient maritimes soit restreint entre le
liban et israël et à cause de richesse
de dégazer des pétroles c'est possible
que ça pourrait être l'étincelle dans le
conflit autrement dit aussi il ya
toujours le raid israélien contre le lac
sirénia en seriez et les menaces des
résulats de répondre
un premier raid là bas la tension est
toujours en cours à cette frontière
israélo libanaise et donc il y a un
problème au lithium de prétendre que les
réseaux la détient beaucoup domicile
très précise et demande à l'état
libanais de les démanteler
donc la fine il reste donc lé monde
déstabilisation pour n'est pas à vendre
car ali ben ben heureusement tout entier
et les dans les caveaux donc voilà on
peut pas au mois il y à un dispositif
pourrait un jour être utiles pour
stabiliser les banques et pour cela je
pense on regarde pas la finir simplement
pour nos frontières et sans ménez mais
peut-être comme une seule force de
réserve pour d'autres missions
si la situation l'imposé alors un
élément de stabilisation ou venez de
nous le dire mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
retenir de l'action de la finul depuis
sa création en 1978
écoutez la finul comme beaucoup des
missions de l'onu
c'est une mission qui sépare des années
qu'ils comptaient consacre un fait
accompli
oh moi quand même la finir en l'an 2000
lors de l'été de l'armée israélienne du
liban
elle a contribué à dessiner ce qu'on
appelle la ligne bleue ont créé ces
libanais il y a toujours un petit
conflit autour des fermes de chebaa mais
grosso modo elle a créé cette commission
a été effectué elle soutient la
population civile au sud liban et la
syrie aussi l'aspect la population
civile israélienne au nord d'israël
donc elles n'arrivent pas bien sûr
lorsqu'il ya une tension énorme où des
accrochages comme c'était le cas entre
palestiniens et israéliens avant 1982
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui entre les
résultats et sahel la fine il ne
parvient pas à les assumer son rôle et
là c'est les blacks presse c'est à dire
là il faut vraiment voir comment donner
à cette mission un contenu et de la
substance pour empêcher une grande
déflagration il est bon
pour conclure cette dernière question le
secrétaire général du hezbollah hassan
nasrallah a déclaré que son organisation
était prête à discuter du nouveau pacte
politique proposée par la france pour le
liban comment est-ce que vous
interprétez cette déclaration écoutez
pour le moment la france n'a pas proposé
ces partis politiques la france c'est
beaucoup de pression pour former un
gouvernement pour tenter de sortir de
l'impasse politique au liban
elle est prise dans ma classe c est là
pour célébrer la descente le premier
centenaire de la naissance du liban sous
la halle et sous la halle et les ailes
sous le mandat français en 1920 mais
bien sûr pour la france les relais
rajouter si ce dialogue avec le
hezbollah et l'iran à propos de libre
mais pour le moment il faut le dire haut
et fort que les résultats nuls et les
rangs fait tout pour ne pas respecter la
souveraineté libanaise et le hezbollah
qui est un état dans l'état fait tout
pour empêcher une nouvelle étable
solution au libor ou un renforcement de
l'état libanais merci beaucoup khattar
abou diab d'avoir répondu à nos
questions rappelle que vous êtes
politologue spécialiste du moyen-orient